[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute galaxy
cupcakes und ich wollte schon immer mal
machen und jetzt habe ich auch einen
besonderen grund denn ich darf euch das
neue buch von der autorin mini dank
vorstellen unter einem guten stern vom
goldmann verlag das besondere ist es ist
heute erschienen heute am 21 oktober und
ich durfte es einige wochen im voraus
lesen ich mach das mal so lesen wir
immer auf der rückseite die
zusammenfassung durch und wenn mir die
zusagt dann wird das buch verschlungen
und so habe ich es auch gemacht und das
gefällt mir richtig richtig gut ich gehe
auch gerne im laufe des videos mal auf
dem inhalt ein ohne zu spoilern
so viel kann ich schon mal verraten ist
dreht sich um horoskope und daher auch
die wunderbaren galaxy cupcakes und
dafür machen wir zuallererst muffins und
schoko muffins mit ganz schön dicken
chocolate chance ließ am liebsten mag
und neben den benötigen wir noch die
folgenden grund zutaten die es sicher
alle daheim habt mehr außerdem ein
besten zimmer waren zucker kakao das ist
der stark enthüllte hier habe ich noch
backpulver zimmer warme butter und
lauwarme milch auch wenn ich jetzt die
küchenmaschine benutze um den muffin
teig zubereiten könnt ihr natürlich auch
euer handrührgerät verwenden die gibt
jetzt zuallererst die butter zusammen
mit dem zucker in die maschine und rückt
das dann richtig schön hält cremig und
dabei hilft euch der zucker den gibt ja
am besten auch schon mit dazu
[Musik]
nach zwei minuten gibt dann die eier
dazu lass dir ganz kurz einrühren und
verrät schon mal die trockenen zutaten
miteinander
dann können sie sich schon mal im
vorfeld besser miteinander verbinden und
die sehen wir jetzt abwechselnd mit der
lauwarme milch in die teigmasse geht
dabei am besten runter mit eurer stufe
so dass eben nicht überschwappt oder die
küche nicht eingebaut wird
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt aus wenn ihr die
trockenen zutaten und die milch dazu
gegeben habe und dafür jetzt noch die
chocolate chance die ich jetzt nur noch
ganz kurz ein röhre den ofen habe ich
auch schon vorgeheizt war finde ich
immer in den vorgeheizten backofen leben
und jetzt dem vorbereiteten tag einfach
in die muffin förmchen einfüllen
jetzt machen wir die muffins bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze für 22 minuten
und danach lassen wir sie vollständig
auskühlen
[Musik]
während die schoko muffins jetzt
abkühlen erzähle ich euch noch ein
bisschen was über die handlung ist dreht
sich nämlich alles um die große liebe
wie auch sonst ich liebe bücher die von
liebe handeln und wenn sie dann noch
liebevoll geschrieben sind und sich
einfach lesen dann ist es für mich
perfekt es geht darum dass die
journalistin justine in einem oder für
ein star magazin arbeitet und dort in
einer etage einfach zugriff auf die
horoskope hat ihr kennt natürlich in
zeitschriften die verschiedensten
horoskope die da immer geschrieben
werden und sie selber glaubt da nicht so
dran aber ihre jugendliebe denn liegt er
glaubt an und er ließ das sogar und so
versucht sie das horoskop für ihn
einfach zu verändern und dann ihnen
damit zu sich zu finden ob das gelingt
verrat ich euch noch nicht aber es gibt
auch viele nebencharaktere im buch und
das finde ich auch super super schön
geschrieben man hat nämlich nicht nur
einblick in diese große geschichte
sondern auch auf viele andere charaktere
und am ende haben alle irgendwie etwas
miteinander zu tun und es liest sich
einfach so kommt weil das eben auch so
kurze knackige sätze sind es ist nicht
zu langatmig und wusste auch immer
wieder so ein bisschen schmunzeln bei
einigen passagen und wir machen jetzt
auch schon direkt weiter mit dem
forsting
das können wir zu keiner zwischenzeit
machen während die muffins abkühlen
dafür benötigen wir auch nur vier
zutaten habt ihr schon vorbereitet das
ist einmal butter dieses zimmer waren
die habe ich hier schon in der
rührschüssel dann habe ich doppel ram
frischkäse nimmt auch gerne in doppel
ram frischkäse und nicht die fettarme
variante
hier habe ich für die süße noch butter
zucker und vanille extrakt wer den nicht
hat kann auch wenn er zog an ihm aber
der schmeckt ein bisschen intensiver
[Musik]
die butter habe ich zusammen mit
puderzucker und vanille extrakt zehn
minuten lang auf mittlerer stufe richtig
schön cremig geschlagen und schaut euch
das ergebnis an
also es sieht schon gar nicht mehr aus
sie butter sondern es ist einfach cremig
es ist beides hat man aber konsistent
und für den geschmack ist auch wichtig
dass sie die zehn minuten ein haltet ihr
können durch alternativ wieder ein
handrührgerät verwenden und im nächsten
schritt gehen wir jetzt mit einem talk
show aber ganz wichtig nicht mehr die
maschine benutzen die den frischkäse mit
dazu und den bringen wir jetzt so lange
unter bis sich alles miteinander
verbunden hat und nicht länger und dann
ist es frosting fertig das frosting wenn
wir uns aufteilen einmal durch drei und
dann wird jedes drittel einmal ein
gefährt jeweils schwarz violett und blau
[Musik]
um mit diesen effekten den drei farben
zu erhalten nehmt euch einfach drei
spritzbeutel führt die farben mit dem
force teams jeweils rein und gibt es
dann in einen großen spritzbeutel mit
einer stelle vorne dran und er zeige ich
euch den effekt indem ich hier häufig
spritzen
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich hier noch gold rauf
so wie auf dem cover das ist ja auch
schön gold und natürlich ein paar
streusel meine cupcakes sind jetzt für
kurze zeit im kühlschrank aber nur so
lange bis ich hier die restliche deko
fertig gemacht habe und dafür nehme ich
mir ganz einfach back opladen gibt es
das ganze jahr über im kühlschrank und
ich nehme hier zwei weil mir eine
einfach zu dünn ist und als kleber
nehmen uns einfach ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe und drücken das dann
zusammen mit der lebensmittelfarbe
können wir die dann auch aus meinen
[Musik]
ich habe mich für violett und blau
entschieden das ist einfach stimmig mit
dem restlichen cupcake und da gebe ich
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen gold spree
um drauf und dann bis heute ich mir
schon ausgedruckt nehme ich mich hier
zur vorlage diese sternzeichen ist es
halt immer besser wenn man ab und zu mal
drauf stehen kann und zeichne die dann
mit einem witz armen den lebensmittel
farbstift auf und die mafia überleg dir
dann ganz einfach auf eure creme und
fertig sind die galaxy cupcakes ich
persönlich für die wunderschön und ich
mag die auch total gerne weil ich liebe
schokolade und wir haben einen leckeren
schoko muffins und das cream cheese
forsting gibt nochmal diese besondere
frische rein und jetzt gibt es auch
etwas zu gewinnen ich habe mich stark
gemacht und habe überlegt wir können
auch noch was verlosen und die idee kam
einfach gut an und daher habe ich hier
fünf dieser exemplare für euch und ich
würde mal sagen teilnehmen könnt ihr
indem ihr mir in die kommentare schreibt
welches sternzeichen ihr seid und damit
macht er klar ich möchte am gewinnspiel
teilnehmen und ihr hilft automatisch in
den lostopf und in sieben tagen wo sich
dann aus und schreibe die gewinne an bzw
schreibe sie hier in die infobox und da
findet ihr auch noch mal alle
teilnahmebedingungen und ganz wichtig
die mengenangaben für das rezept und ich
würde sagen ganz viel freude beim
nachmachen und falls ihr euch das buch
kaufen sollte dann viel freude am lesen
dann können wir uns auch gerne darüber
austauschen gerne auch hier in den
kommentaren kaum so zeigt gerade mit dem
finger ja ich bin löwe und haben sie du
bist fischer deswegen habe ich hier mit
fischer auch angefangen habe ich direkt
und nicht dagegen musste und jetzt
wünsche ich euch wie gesagt ganz viel
freude und hoffe dass ihr bei meinem
nächsten video auch wieder einschaltet
tschüss
[Musik]